[Applause]
hi oh my goodness okay
is this a good time to quickly just say
that chloe and i
also worked together we made a short
film for a band called best coast
you are the muse of all muses and it was
just the biggest dream and
she would call me mama flea and i would
call her baby flea
that was our thing okay we have so much
to talk about
i'm so excited to talk about tom and
jerry it's like
i'm freaking out um but let's quickly
mention design because we just parlayed
from these extraordinary influencers
and um you got the same dresser and
we're gonna
do it together let's take a look at your
dresser
oh my gosh
take us through your design choices how
did you do this
um i really love like the the the kind
of feeling of the white oaks the natural
um uh wood is something that i love in
my house i want to keep it kind of
simple on the outside but i love the
little leather pull tabs it kind of
gives it a nice
uh functional but also kind of different
than your your typical kind of drawer
pull
and then i love cane i have caning on so
many of
the furniture that i have in my house so
i really want to do this kind of cabinet
um look so you can actually fit more
inside there
and the caning just gives it nice
dimension um and it you know is similar
to the stuff that i have in my house
and then of course on the inside um is a
little pride flag because uh we're
donating
the proceeds to the lgbt la center
absolutely beautiful innovative i am
so inspired and i can't fake it when it
comes to design
i am so impressed with what you did
well thank you you know when when um i
had the chance to go to your halloween
party but the one thing that really like
struck me was your house is so intricate
and so wonderful and there was so much
design behind every room and every room
felt like
you know a new kind of corner and a new
story um and so i i definitely see that
in in your life and it's it's something
that i really i do as well in mine
thank you i do think that it's a great
idea in design that every room can be
its own little world maybe it
should cohesively work together but
that's sort of
every room the same matchy-matchy that
almost feels like old school
hiring a designer and then they don't
know you and you don't know them and
it's just weird
i did this with my dresser i'm proud to
say
i think mine is the least exciting
because everyone else did such a good
job
this is exactly what i was hoping for um
so i went with like
uh i thought what if this needed to be
in a bedroom and was an extension of
storage
for clothes and closets so i did
sweaters i added some books and some
flowers
just to kind of you know give it a
little more of a decorative vibe on top
you could also set a little tv on top of
it
if it's in a bedroom and then the
drawers i
actually um covered with flower
wallpaper which is a wallpaper i design
and then put these um wood and gold uh
trims on it so um yeah
i'm i'm i feel like i got schooled today
and that's exactly what i was hoping for
so chloe and i this is very important as
chloe mentioned
for her lgbtq rainbow flag inside of her
dresser we're going to be donating
our drawer chest to the los angeles lgbt
center and for more information about
that
you can go and bid on these items all of
them
and uh visit our website which is so
great
so this design really does have a
purpose and a soul behind it
and that's really what makes it the most
beautiful so thank you
for doing that with me chloe and all of
[Applause]
[Music]
us